what's more important why or vision
they're equally is important they're
different things so why comes from the
past remember it's an origin story it's
where we come from and to discover your
why you look backwards in your life we
look for patterns across our life when
things were naturally going extremely
well we look for patterns we can
identify that pattern that is our why
it's the thing that we give to the world
it comes from the past it is the
foundation of who we are vision is where
we're going it's about the future it's
about imagination it's not based on
something objective vision is entirely
subjective your why is objective you
have one it never changes for your whole
life your vision is subjective you can
pick any vision you want it's the world
you're trying to build preferably it's
good to stick to one vision tweak it
every now and then because otherwise
you're all over the place but you can
have more than you can only have one y
and everybody has one you can have
multiple visions you can have one for
your family one for your company you can
have one for your community you can have
multiple visions you can apply them
differently so I like to talk about
vision as a just cause mainly because
there's no standard definition of vision
and so many organizations and
individuals like my vision is to be a
millionaire my vision is to I mean
that's not a vision that's just a goal
that's why I call it a just cause so for
me vision is about just cause of cause
so just that we would willingly
sacrifice in order to help advance this
cause so think of it like a house why is
the foundation of the house once you
build a foundation it's there it's solid
it's what gives the organization or you
or our lives structure but you don't
change the foundation that's it now you
can have a vision of the house you want
to build of the life you want to lead or
the company you want to build and you
build on the foundation so there's basic
structure that's gonna remain the same
but you can change the shutters you can
add floors you can expand you can expand
you can redecorate so vision is where
the house is going why is where the
house is coming from where it's built
upon
[Music]
you